once the haircut catches on you know
you're gonna take credit for that [__]
oh you're actually hands took credit for
a guy that didn't get the haircut oh
yeah buddy
Wesley Snipes had it in place so yeah
once didn't kill it actually and
everybody loved that [__] I think the
90s are really coming back but was that
the 90s
Demolition Man everything's the 90s what
was it blade not blame Demolition Man he
was blonde oh yeah yeah yeah but blady
had that exact cut yeah I saw I saw Luca
I got gassed up Luca put a picture on
his story of him getting his fate yeah
but the barber set the line for the fade
first and he posted the picture and it
looked like it was just my cut and I was
like they right
I text the group I texted multiple group
chats I was like yeah where's your jokes
now when the greatest white NBA player
ever got my [__] haircut first they
do it then they cop that's it exactly I
think that's what I said
it is it is the next story I didn't even
go to the next story because I was so
excited I clicked the next story Fade
All in regular haircut that he already
has
didn't call on just yet but it's coming
bro it's coming don't we will he will no
it's definitely coming though it's gonna
come yeah people gonna get the face but
you gotta stay with it yo I don't get
things I catch them son
I catch Fades bro yeah you give me
wait let me try it one more time
it wasn't enough black people there
listen Okay okay
come on Blanche
come on stop playing with me right now
I'll stop playing with me what is it I
don't get wait I don't get Fades I give
them I give fades I don't catch fades no
I don't get Fades I give them
Workshop it a little yeah